oh by the way this is a friend of mine
tree hi I'm Steve Rogers hey everybody
its charlie I'm beginning a lot of
requests to do a video for guardians of
the galaxy news there's also some Thor
stuff happening just because tyga has
been in the news because of all this
Guardian stuff he was seen at Marvel
recently so there are a lot of rumors
flying around no worries I'll explain
what's going on there's new infinity war
giveaway stuff I'll explain at the end
of the video be sure to subscribe to get
everything the reason why you're seeing
all these news alerts and all this talk
is because the Hollywood trades are
reporting that people inside Marvel have
unofficially confirmed the guardians of
the galaxy theory is being pulled from
the Marvel schedule originally it was
scheduled to be released spring 2020
with no official hard date now the word
from inside Marvel is is that well we
can't miss our release state if we
technically never officially said what
the release date was so they're just
splitting hairs but the talk is is that
they're taking their time and finding a
new director to replace James Gunn on
the film originally they were scheduled
to start shooting in January that's why
they're talking about the film being
pushed in the schedule so they've
released all the crew that we're working
on pre-production to seek other work
meaning that they don't intend on
releasing it when they originally did so
because of that there are a couple
things that need to happen next there
are a couple directors at the top of the
list like I said the tyka is in the news
he was the first people started talking
about because he was seen at Marvel
recently having a meeting so people are
like well he was already planning Thor
for maybe he's also there now to talk
about guardians 3 because if you already
have a big director then they're not
planning on making that next door film
for a while it means he's available so
it's like well if you're awesome we love
you we want you to do another film what
a coincidence we have this giant film
that's ending a trilogy that we really
want to release during 2020 so Tyga was
at Marvel for a whole bunch of things
but also to shoot a new promo as coorg
like new footage as coorg for Marvel
contest of Champions good evening
everyone and welcome to the first
meeting of the revolution 2.0 or as I
like to call it the re revolution uncork
I'm kind of the leader here and this
little guy by my side is meek he doesn't
do much but I feel bad for stead
I'm a couple of weeks back so I hired
him as our new recruitment officer quick
roll call the Summoner present angry
lady present anyway these are our new
candidates meat found these guys on the
internet some of them have a lot of
followers so if we can get them to join
the revolution will be a success or at
least we'll get a lot of likes Kevin
Feige said that he already wanted to
bring him back for one of those one
shots like Corrigan meek just doing
mundane stuff like a team Darrell video
the actor that plays Daryl released a
new team Daryl video - wishing Chris
Hemsworth happy birthday so Daryl is
also confirmed alive in the MCU good
news
Daryl survived the snap bad news a lot
of my co-workers didn't so I'm working
Sundays this video is to say happy
birthday though however many thousands
of years old you are I hope you're
having a good time out there in the
universe and if there happens to be
Wi-Fi where you are if you could just do
a quick transfer I mean quite a bit of
debt since you left
happy birthday Thor I miss you and I
hope you're having a good day so just to
be clear yes there will be a fourth Thor
film but it's not gonna happen for a
while so they're just talking about it
right now so it's not like they're gonna
fast-track that and you'll see - Thor
films within the span of a couple years
of each other so new Guardians director
is problem one problem to now is that
they need to replace that Guardians
spring 2020 release date with another
Marvel film right now there are only two
films that I know that they have that
are far enough along that they could get
out by spring 2020 either because
they're just far enough along in
production and the scripts are done or
they don't require a lot of special
effects so it takes them less time to
get the movie out and that's the black
widow movie because they already have a
director they have a script they have a
writer so they're just far enough along
and it doesn't require nearly as many
special effects as say like a big black
panther film or a spider-man film the
other film being Doctor Strange - if you
don't remember there was a video I did a
couple days ago because the British
trades are reporting that Benedict
Cumberbatch is going to be getting ready
to shoot Doctor Strange - sometime next
year
meaning if those reports are true they
were already going to shoot Doc
strange - they could just move that up
in the schedule a little bit right now
blacc panther2 is definitely going to
happen but it's currently scheduled for
spring 2021 a year after her Guardians
was supposed to come out so I don't
think that that's nearly far enough
along in production they haven't locked
ryan coogler down for that even though
he's definitely coming back they just
haven't finished signing all the
contracts we don't know if they have a
script yet and because it's one of their
crown jewel franchises next to the
Avengers films and spider-man they're
definitely gonna take their time to get
the Black Panther sequel right so that's
why it's scheduled for three years down
the road that's how long they plan on
spending developing the film which I
think will be awesome but it eventually
gets here but we need a smaller Marvel
film that doesn't require a ton of
special effects or one that's ready to
go in until Kevin Feige announces what
their other plans are for phase four the
only ones we know about are Black Widow
in Doctor Strange - a while ago Kevin
Feige confirmed that they're releasing
three films per year going forward now
that was before all this guardians crap
ended up happening so best-case scenario
they find a new director before the end
of the year they released guardians
three later say like November twenty
twenty and just find one of those
smaller films to replace it spring
release date so you still get your three
films during 2020 you still get
guardians three in that same year but
you have a couple extra months for
whichever new director they bring on to
do his own polish of James Gunn's script
because if they bring in a big director
they're probably gonna want to put their
own spin on the material right now aside
from tyka the other really big director
that just became available was Danny
Boyle you probably heard the news about
how he quit bond 25 because he had a
disagreement with Daniel Craig in the
broccolis about who to cast for the
villain of the film so he walked
he's totally available now he's a really
badass director he's not known for doing
a lot of comedies or really humorous
films he does films that are really good
that have humor in them but he's a
director with vision he's very powerful
in the filmmaking world so he would
definitely want to do his own pass on
James Gunn script which would add a
couple extra months to their production
schedule the backup option this is
actually pretty exciting but I don't
know that it would happen is is that
Bradley Cooper rocket racoon himself
wants to direct films he
directed a star is born he is another
film called Bernstein that is getting
ready to direct so because all the
actors loved him there used to him he'd
be like the easiest person to slot in
next to taiga probably even easier than
taiga it's just that he doesn't have the
experience directing a film that big he
would probably just require a little
extra support from the Marvel producers
in Kevin Feige just to make sure
everything runs smoothly so let me know
in the comments who do you want them to
get to direct guardians 3 Tyga bradley
cooper danny boyle somebody else and
what film do you want them to replace it
with in the spring like i said there's a
new round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway going on all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from my last big video deku
mario please email me on the about page
of my youtube channel so i can get your
contact details click here for that new
Captain Marvel villain teaser and click
here to learn all about the black widow
movie thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you